aung san suu kyi estará detenida
preventivamente hasta el 15 de febrero
el ejército de mianmar le acusa de una
supuesta posesión de un set de walkie
talkies importados ilegalmente radios
con quedó todas sus guardaespaldas si es
condenada podría recibir hasta tres años
de cárcel las naciones unidas- rechazan
la detención
creo que los cargos presentados contra
ella sólo agravan el socavamiento del
estado de derecho en mianmar y el
proceso democrático
el ejército continúa clausurándose desde
la liga nacional para la democracia el
partido de suu kyi aunque empezó a
liberar a los 350 parlamentarios que
tenía retenidos
xavi a mayo mientras mina online jefe
del ejército ya se reúne con sus nuevos
ministros analistas consideran que los
militares están haciendo lo habitual en
un golpe de estado
estaba claro que los militares iban a
buscar algunos casos legales contra los
líderes de la liga nacional para la
democracia y especialmente contra sus y
de esta forma legítima en lo que
intentaron hacer así es una toma de
poder
las protestas continúan la comunidad de
mianmar en el extranjero salió a las
calles de japón y tailandia en el país
personal de salud de más de 70
hospitales dejó de trabajar en plena
pandemia como desobediencia social y
esto es yang gon
la principal ciudad del país el golpe es
un insulto la gente vivía en paz y las
cosas estaban estables y lo han
destruido todo la presión internacional
crece contra los militares que condenan
dow a succi buscan evitar que participe
en las próximas elecciones comicios
previstos para dentro de un año cuando
prometieron disolver la junta militar